today's big story the matchup between us  number one Hikaru Nakamura and world  number one Magnus Carlsen Hikaru came to  the board looking smooth and ready for a  fight and he played this rambunctious  move b5 would seem to rattle his  opponent and after putting a lot of  pressure on Carlson the game eventually  ended in a draw I felt like I actually  played quite a while but I'm not really  sure if it was ever enough to let in the  other game between the US Champion gata  kamsky and world number two Levon  Aronian both players seem to not want to  lose more than to win after what seemed  like some chances for both sides the  game eventually ended in a quiet draw be  sure to join us Friday for Round four  action of the sink field cup here in st.  Louis at one p.m. Central or follow us  live at st. Louis chess club com